[Music]
yesterday passing 360 so we're going to introduce you to
roland garros or not somewhere around
the corner at all so for that we're
two examples - who is suspicious
Olympic at the 2004 Paralympic saber fencing games
hello me I  presents to you for mesnil
en seine olympic athletes and who
participated in four olympic games
sign athens london and beijing y lévis
double world champion knows that thank you
with like a gentle will be your guides
in this immersive show
as roman previously recalled
the  English in which we are going to
discover the duo is very wide
so in fact if you see you can
turn in the line look behind
us to the right to the left so we are
really in the heart of roland garros on
the place of the earth muscles because
roland garros this  year it's
infrastructure new
infrastructure in that's why
we showed that on missions
the first show will really be
devoted to infrastructure  uctures it's
today in two days we will do
an even more special program
which will be really oriented on the
unknown professions of roland garros and
finally next week we have two
other resignations a program
on Olympism and the last which will be the  9
will really be on the assessment of the
achievements and his hair his new
iphone os
so we will make a perfect little assessment
it's a nice program
so I had the pleasure of
meeting zine day in the project manager
who is there  origin of this
magnificent complex and its innovations
and its transformations and I
suggest that you watch this
interview room together this afternoon
a magnificent garden of greenhouses rise
the dam return
doctor receives makes the function of
master builder of inclinations  mop of
blond hair reassures us it is he who pays the
bulk who makes a program that makes
a nice row and even sees it there and
who follows and who does work to
grit his golden teeth
from this site in the in the locality
so this job so yes it is to do
if we have if we already have recognition
it is that for me I am no
longer years old thank you while they have been
wronged novation this  year compared
to previous years
this year we see above all the end
of two operations
from previous years have actually
done everything that was outside the
glasses of water from the networks or the surfaces
the floors and then some elements
like three  short annexes and then a
large shop and and the large
entrance forecourt we have completed the last phase
of work
there is still a little bit left because the
metro says that I was always in good shape
so thank you
what is the impact of  these on
the experience of the players
as well as on the fans and lovers
of tennis and reviews
listen to the feedback are mostly positive
ever what else can you
tell me about future innovations
once roland garr  os has finished
to allow you
it is for the players to live a
total experience and is quite rich
the players the players the players and
the players have already discovered last year
the facilities
directly concerning them the dac locker room
for restoration of technical innovations
for a particular reason
[Music
] three hundred are
special because going to 360 so
we're going to introduce you to
roland garros or listening at all
so for that we are two so
I present to you - el assine who is
an Olympic medalist at the 2004
fencing games  at the saber paralympic games
hello hand I present to you as a
mesnil in skits shoulder to the peak and
who participated in four olympic games
sign athens london and beijing y lévis
double world champion knows that thank you
with roman you will be your guides in
this mission  and immersive
as Romain recalled previously
the English in which we are going to
discover the silly game is very broad
so has some  ide if you see you can
turn in the line look behind
us to the right to the left so we are
really in the heart of roland garros on
the place des mousquetaires
because extending the rise this
year is the infrastructures
new infrastructures in it is
for  that's what we showed that on missions
the first show will be really
dedicated to infrastructures done
today in two days we will do
an even more special show
which will be really oriented on the
unknown professions of roland garros and
finally next week we  has two
other programs a program
on Olympism and the last one which will be on the 9th
will be really on the assessment of the
achievements and his hair his new
iphones
so we will do a perfect little assessment
it's a nice program has some so I
have  had the pleasure of meeting one day
in the project manager who is at
the origin of this magnificent complex and
its innovations and its transformations
and I propose to you  e watch together
this this interview this afternoon
thank you not to receive on this magnificent
garden of the two brothers under the cloak
and tell us about your desire to go the
rare job for the benefit of the function of
project manager the screen
also sings  course in sirte is the one
who pays for basically what makes a
program that makes a program aeae
leaves once there and who follows and
who works for that and hears them in
gold
as much as possible in time
then block it this job  so this version there
if we already have a good knowledge and
that for me
I am about ten years old thank you
what were the innovations
this year compared to
previous years this year we see
especially at the end of the operation
the  previous years we often did
everything that was outside the
verbs the networks the surfaces the floors
and then some elements like three
short annexes and then they will take
the public and the big one among d  n these
cases we have completed the last phase
of north-east work for a bit because
the tax rate to win
another form in toulouse
so versailles
what is the impact of these on the
experiences of players
and on  fans and lovers
of tennis and film critics
listen to the feedback is quite positive
what more can you
tell me about future
innovations once roland garros has finished
to allow players
to experience a
total experience and is quite rich in leaves
the players the players the
players have already discovered last year
the facilities
directly concerning them the locker room
tac restoration of technical innovations
for
there were bodies training their
hotels experience it back  in egypt
there what we expect this year we have two
high schools it is the return which seems
to be active on all types short annex
it is a short annex is im  wearing this
is where it happens currents
taxing the matches are tight the heads
of this title to the atmosphere and here we are
close to the we are close to the game and so I
would say that the adjoining courts resonate
well with their expression network  becomes the
14 no one imagines
ok that we had it does not concern the thousand
pleasures of attending a few matches
on these different and that was
important that remains we had it started
ian taele finding it is not easy  and
then the second the second thing that
works well and that is also important
is it's the lighting of the
shorts a second subject he should
call and we're fine
so the watch or right next to the
chatrier and we have behind  we the
suzanne lenglen who will be future site of
the
olympic games damon so what
would make them all
innovation to allow our players
as well as the fans to live an
incredible enriched experience so what
he said and I'm leaving don  to make
these  games a unique moment
what is going to be fun is that on the
roland garros site is really
having two and programmatically important
his words
and in particular there will be boxing
knowing that this is a story with
notes here for those who
they  are blue like me a port our
forests which are even more beautiful than me
they saw marcel cerdan at the trial here
we were with gil jourdan the project manager
of roland garros who was
kind enough to present to us the
innovations carried out on the
infrastructures  for more also the
projects for paris 2024 we thank
gil jourdan and we find ourselves with
romaine on the virtual tour
thank you for having us
have you talked about
your job m these news are there
we just have to sort in front  of us
so there tonga is not one it is
another left we have the esplanade of the
musketeers and in the background the
new roland garros boutique behind
there is what yes alas we have  s before last
month the court simone mathieu better
hide there is something at sema bas and
there we have there superb
classic gifts simon we are in the heart of
roland garros my total and loire
what do i think he is  there is
someone who has planned videos for
the watches elsewhere already that one of that
I have passed the videos are ready we are
looking at what suddenly we keep the statue
of rafah come on we start with that
so its statutes we went to
see it  this then me I had my
picture taken
we have a goal that he is someone is
delivering next door exactly there was our friend
nelson monfort who were there the statue
really impressive the impression
of having his chestnuts so the  take everything
in beta with holes like that it
gives a great feeling when we
arrive it's the arrival of all the
spectators a player who is still
active
true legend we will look at
another another site what are you going to I  suggest
that we go to the esplana  of the
mosques complained about the musketeers
in control this party
the four musketeers so if we make
the legend of French tennis yes and the
guard then we can walk there between
and there they have actually installed
deck chairs to be able to take advantage
of the  matches on the giant screen took
advantage of it no we invite you to
discover the court philippe chatrier
this magnificent complex with its
huge and retractable roof so it is
architecturally speaking it is a masterpiece
I finally because  there is this side a bit
I won't go stuffing would put it here is very
rural
and then like such and such a
jean tower tithe relief and it's almost
a football field what these rooms look
like a football stadium in england we
keep a  stadium it's in any case
in harmony is perfect
shoe that I think you as an
athlete as a tennis player we
do well in there or impress it
depends on the Greek characters it's very
true  in you  In any case, it gives rise to
exceptional encounters and matches
so here it is, all
the conditions are met to
welcome all the players and
all the players from all over the world in
the best conditions.
else to
show no we
leave it on that for this time super fmg we invited
surprise well played afterwards by a chain
at the microphone but in fact he did not see
coming if he in toulouse cécile blacks
c  it was planned he was coming to toulouse he is
an olympic champion also that of
fabien gilot olympic
swimming champion so fabien who has finished his
career hello done well hello roman
and the water fabien thank you a lot of milk
came on this virtual all in mode
virtual
how about tursan that you can't
follow us well all the missions yeah
of course well listen it's fabulous to
see these new facilities and
as a former athlete I think it
must galvanize all the players for the
this year's tournament
yeah what are you doing fabien
now that you are you swim more that's
it and the people in front are the scores
i stopped after the rio games took
my fourth puppy we finished with a
medal  money so I stay close to
the sport close to the circle of swimmers of
marseille where I have a function as a member of
the local athletes' commission
so play on the organizing committee of the Olympics and
then I took over the hat of my
studies j  I have insurance firms
specializing in business risks
setup bravo beautiful reconversion is a
little exchanged advance with them always
good to see athletes who manage
to convert and it is that it works
now the federations are doing more and
more  of work in any case it's well
done so suddenly on the
infrastructures until interesting to
know what I have my opinion on
the infrastructures in pole vaulting
what it gives but get some taste
fabien a  p  swimming pool an Olympic swimming pool
and another swimming pool does the same thing
no it's water it's fifty
meters there are differences already the
pools are regulated so it's
exactly the same builder and the
manufacturers involved in all
the competitions  international for
the approval of records and then we
have seen swimming evolve in recent
years where
I think that one of the most beautiful
infrastructures that we have known as
a swimmer was the cube during the
Beijing games which was  a rage a
fabulous work and the more the years have
passed the more the requests of spectators
have evolved and today we end up
asking me swimming pools in the middle
of the football stadiums in particular to have a maximum
of reception capacity so the stadium is
cut  in two or a third to be able to
accommodate the public we very
rarely fill a stadium but in any case
the energy of a stadium the resonance of a
stadium the whole infrastructure for me it
puts  more atmosphere and it is
above all that in my opinion it galvanizes the
athletes the more beautiful it is the more
ambitious it is the more impressive it is
around us and the more I think there
is performance on the side in Rennes
in  done there what you are describing there it is indeed that
fabien yes exactly
it is this atmosphere it is there it is the
deafening side of the noise of the
viewers were spectators
sorry and I feel that this is what we are
looking for  all a little bit high
level we like the adrenaline of the d-day we
like having this ball in the stomach being
afraid is finally more spectators the
more the environment of the performance
and the infrastructure is impressive the
more it puts stress the more it puts
pressure, that's one thing, but I
think that as a general rule it galvanizes
the athletes and it pushes them to achieve
even more incredible performances
than it looks, concretely I
agree 100% with what this  that Fabien
us and to tell us it's quite
unbelievable  able to feel this to the
crowd that carries you it's a
feeling but which is unique and as
you say we all seek this state
there when we are a top athlete
because we need it will be able to rise
and to reach them to get
incredible performances on their
feelings you athens
yes yeah the first games moreover
this time impressed you weren't
impressed were planning to arrive that would tell you
or there is a little doubt abandoned
the last pass and saw a little
long abandoned especially when you
enter it at the stadium
me I was marked by athens by 2.2
points which was the first it was the
opening ceremony
my first games and because I have
just described that's it c  it's just a bag
already listening on the second opening
but you felt that to carry you
for the days to come and that's
really really important it's the
game side the players who are there for his
passion with exactly  there  or you
say what's your ride oh you have ideally
or that it ideally does it she
is in france
the ideal is the grand palace
i used it in two months sebha is tired of
all this phenomenon of feeling carried
by his ball no longer at home, therefore by
his own supporters, but the main
alley has been transformed to host
the world championships in
handisport fencing and its presentation
for France to set up this
championship of  world so they said we're
coming to the final and the feeling darren
dein piste was in the middle
and on both sides we were washing the supporters
and that's really that sent me back to
athens and those belgians in the
unique moments and  me so far still
goosebumps at 12 o'clock I think that caen
has tackled the various events well the
citc must have reminded him of
certain emotions and Walloons so me
indeed then fake fault petibon
speaking with a pole there is the wind that it
there is a lot of influence  ence and sometimes
I love a small stadium because the
wind is always oriented in the same
direction so the conditions are
good but that's my rational side
and afterwards indeed a
big stadium but each time at the
olympic games we will always see it
starts to behave again the wind in
a stadium and that is very important and
in the big stadiums which are fabulous
there is always this little wind
swirling so when I have
younger teachers and fsu and  how are we
going to get out of it and then at the end if you
prepare to jump in conditions that are a
little a little difficult different winds and
tell me well the saltiness like that we adapt let's
take advantage of the energy of the stadium
but it's  it's true that I hear a whole
stadium that is the soul and the pole vault
foundations of the cage before each jump
and as for a part of the stadium that gives
the slap that you from everyone
but afterwards it's the same for  all the
firefighters have so anyway it's
not  it is enough that she hides the
offenses it was it was interesting
then there is a particularity here it is
indeed the musketeers yes
behind not if we can see it
here we turn behind so we have the
cases of all that  earth and that
's how legends are made so here when we manage
to as a spectator or not dance the
people from there when they speak to
us perhaps less well we who are not
tennis players these four musketeers and
finally Fabien you are  -that you
had enough of the legends in
swimming which then either led you
to swim at a high
level, either to boost or to transcend
at certain times a three to reinforce or
not yes of course I think that  like
everyone, some of whom are idols when we
are younger then we necessarily
in swimming there was that you know
alexander popov who marked the history
of the olympic games by winning four
titles
so this is an example  we  had
the time ian thorpe the australian
also who swam very fast
and finally it is athletes
who passed before us and in our
sport we are we will not erase a
time barrier and the fact of
breaking records a
few years later  of certain
idols that we could have
also allows us to sanctify to
conceptualize that we fit into a
rather particular category of athletes that
we fit into the big
leagues I want to say but I think that
idols c  it is the magic of sport and
high-level sport as a general rule
is
that through performances we can make people
vibrate and arouse vocations it is
kids in the four corners of the world that
we will never meet and for all that
we will  inspire them with something that
will serve them for life and that
I think is a beauty of sport
and not only in sports and wii in
me I see the huge statue of Raphaël
I think I have a friend his  son
there play  er tennis he is 16 years old and it's true
that he went to their business rafael
nadal from academy so for him it's
raphaël his legend and I think he
wants to give back was born a package that's it
takes  four stars suddenly you had
the screams had a lot of legends and
me one of the legends who marked me the most
in which obviously concerns
the discipline is jean françois lamour
ah yeah ok he's a gentleman  whom
I had the pleasure of meeting on
several occasions but his fencing has
always fascinated me okay I
meet him so have a minister but also
I the professionals
you are very open intrepid 13 years old is
the very warm I don't know  if we had
to meet him on the same occasion return
from the athens games maybe well yeah
maybe there I met for an
apt meeting and also this
tennis side besides this criterion is that the
reader from elsewhere and yeah  it's true
then I was in the grass or a
book the tongues the legs  s and so
if there was this book then it was better
it was a ussr a cessna its height this
big boom case and at the same time i
did my first olympic games in
sydney i saw it gave me  asked to
give him his marks of passage there can
keep this start it would be part
of the legends and then after that there
are others who spoke about what
French land is musketeers also
this stage of doves so it's  a little
further north of paris so there we do
n't necessarily see the camera there among the
flying men of doves,
that is to say that it is at the stadium of
doves the racing club of france there
were the best pole vaulters in the world
that  they were all in the same street
it's thierry vigneron pierre quinon
patrick abada
and and that in fact I had seen a
black and white report that he
showed with slow motion and I had already
started the pair load  to see 17 18
19 years old I'm starting to break through but I
wanted to get into this story
somewhere in me too, a glimpse of a
black and white back, it's also a
question of heritage for
us, he leaves us a legacy that we
too have seen and left for
future generations and beyond the
notion of heritage, as Fabien
knows  where it is also an opportunity to
create vocations for children on
the other side of the planet and that's
really something that is rooted
in shake in every top
athlete and that's really  important you
see we all had our own idols or
as it is your
friend's son who is a fan of raphèle bombs a top
on his infrastructure and the
people we are going to tell the show it was
okay  come and free yourself
thank you very much thank you pies payment
thank you guys it was a pleasure
to be with you and have a good 15th
thank you see you very soon it's going very well
ciao
well I'm very happy this little
discussion it's  is true we come back a bit
to tennis all the same if we  st a little
far away
i think you shot a few a
few videos you tell me that's it there
were a few videos of two players and to
you the management
roland garros brittany ferries it's
cliché but these are the beginnings of
the illustrated  narjess points
[Music]
thank you we saw and lester and now
we are going to look together at the
reactions and the feelings of the
spectators and the fans of roland garros
no no ok
okay do you see a change
[Music]
there is  a lot a lot of changes a
lot of greenery the first thing
you notice - there are fewer people than in
previous years that's
undeniable and then yes a lot more space there
is more common sense which turned
out it's very  nice the atmosphere does
not change the atmosphere on the grounds
does not change yeah in the passageways
in the spans maybe a little bit
but it is still very good child
we will wait for the French without the
action plan so that  this is growing  fe a
little lucid we feel very well
ok and last little question your
predictions for this tournament
[Music]
I would not like nadal to
win again so
come on we will get started I would say then
tried to go ok s'  is offered in
fact thank you I wish you
all an excellent tournament
thank you very much hello thank you for
devoting a little bit of time to me and in
relation to the health crisis is what
you see a small change is
what you appreciate
and well c  it's soon the mass and the end
our show aims to prevent it from
becoming interesting that either the time
has passed very quickly we have time passes
and therefore reduces the next
[Music]
well well it's soon but  it's the
end of our show
this first one is about you time has
passed very quickly
here is time has passed very quickly so
the next one is in two days but
unfortunately same place or almost
and there we are going to talk about the unknown professions
of r  oland garros and i think we're going to
talk about the bird of prey or something
like that we're going to leave the surprise when
already
in two days see you in
days good evening good evening to all
[Music]
[  Music]